bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec mais sur RT France que pensez-vous
de ce nouveau protocole est-ce que c'est
une solution qui vous convient
commencer par dire que tout le monde
aujourd'hui on a un petit peu ras-le-bol
des changements de protocole dans dans
les écoles et pas seulement les
enseignants alors ce protocole des
nouveaux au niveau national mais il
était déjà expérimenté le département
dans le mien la Moselle depuis le mois
d'octobre et dans l'éducation nationale
alimentation devient la norme quelques
semaines plus tard sans même pas le
temps d'analyser les
classes après
on
a des choses à l'école
là où on essaie de faire croire
pour nous c'est ce changement de
protocole il est sûrement économique
le gouvernement a fait le choix de
laisser les écoles
en France parce que si on ferme les
écoles l'économie pour le ralenti et
puis
on a bien vu que le télétravail mais
pour le moment pas le pas à l'ordre du
jour en France
alors
je sais pas si je peux en parler tout de
suite
mon ami les enseignants
[Musique]
comment compter 9002 heures qui vont
fermer leur porte sur ce point-là
précisément qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous
sur le sur l'effet de de fermer à
écouter nous on est
on est les enseignants sont
je pense que c'est important de le
rappeler
après on est sur le terrain
[Musique]
on imagine les difficultés que ça peut
poser le protocole de tête
qui est désormais anciens élèves et
positifs tous ses camarades ont devoir
se faire tester de ceux qui refuse où
sont positives vont devoir rester pour
les premiers 7 jours en isolement et
pour ceux qui sont positifs du jour
oui bon ça va sur un petit peu je
rappelle qu'on demander le dépistage
systématique depuis début c'est calme
encore pas tout à fait la même chose
aujourd'hui on teste les élèves qui sont
un contact sur place si on faisait
plus facilement parce que là il faut
pour que
[Musique]
pour les élèves de
12 ans
oui mais dans les dans les écoles
primaires on a des dépistages qui sont
qui sont encore à la marge
[Musique]
à votre niveau
et
vous rappelle que vous êtes professeur
des écoles en secrétaire